matt damon's wife lucy also made style
waves something not lost on her proud
husband
she's just so beautiful and and and that
that dress was just like lucy's sexy red
versace making her hubby a little
speechless their date night at the
opening of the festival is not something
matt takes for granted i've never opened
the festival before you know i've been
here four other times but never to open
the festival so that was a pretty uh
pretty glamorous night the couple has
been married 11 years and they have four
daughters what's the most romantic thing
you guys like to do in bennett
well we don't have the kids with us so i
mean every moment feels like it's just
it's really uh you know
uh thanks to um the kids grandmother for
staying with them
because we're enjoying every minute get
up and open your eyes the world is
filled with things to see in the movie
matt and kristen wiig are husband and
wife who shrink to five inches tall to
help save the planet it's a community of
miniaturized people where everything is
downsized including their problems i
love the movie it's really
really original i just thought we're
never gonna get the money for this
because it's because it's a big movie
you know there's a lot of special
effects and but it's not like there were
kind of
car chases and the kind of normal bells
and whistles to kind of offset that if
you could shrink yourself in real life
what would you do hide